nikki what's going on hi dr john thank
you so much for taking my call
you bet thanks for calling how are you
i'm good how are you
we are having a blast figuring it out
one
caller at a time i guess i'm still
figuring out what i'm even doing with my
life nikki so we'll get there right
so hey how can i help you what's going
on
so my boyfriend and i have been together
for six years
and we have two babies together
we have a seven we have a seven month
old and a two-year-old
ooh so you're in it now huh yeah a
minute
do you hey do you even know what day it
is
i i actually don't i know it's somewhere
in april
i love that okay um all right so
you have a two-year-old and a seven
month old you don't know what day it is
and i can only guess where this is going
you've been dating this guy for
six years yeah and then what
well so he kind of
so we live together you know we we play
house as dave calls it
okay and he has a hard time with me
well i guess i should say i have a hard
time keeping up with
his kind of expectations
um so he wants me to exercise
more and to get my body back to the way
it was
um but i feel i feel so overwhelmed
but hey just uh just a quick thing does
he know that you have a seven month old
and a two-year-old i think he's picked
that up by now i think i think he might
pick that up myself okay so i
i'm trying to wrap my head around this
walk me through how that actual
conversation takes place
so he sees you breastfeeding a kid and
there's a two-year-old just screaming
and you have dinner cooking and he looks
at you and goes
yeah this body is not cutting it you're
gonna have to fix it like how does that
even happen
he'll get home from work and he'll be
like so did you do your exercise bike
today
gosh what i say no i did not do my
exercise bike today
no dr john i'm dealing with a guy
who has the mindset of jocko
i know but listen i do too i love jocko
i'm gonna do a speaking engagement with
him in a few weeks
i love him and you know what i didn't
never ever did
looked at my wife without holding a
seven month old and be like so how'd
your workout go today babe
you know never you know why because i
have a soul
and i actually care about human beings
right that like i don't care jocko
wouldn't do that to his own wife and
he's got multiple he's got four or five
kids right
god almighty so
i always want to try to find the soul in
somebody what they're trying to trying
to be helpful
is uh
and my body's not even that bad i've
lost 70 pounds
no listen nikki this has nothing to do
with your body so i'm trying to get to a
place where i can empathize with this
guy
before i just hang up on you and i call
him directly
so that's that's not even our main
problem though oh
sweet we'll continue nikki go ahead uh
so he's he thinks i don't
keep the house clean enough oh gosh
nikki listen
and tour toward the point he wants to
kick me out
hey listen go ba
take both of those kids and go i know
i can't do that though hey listen
go
this guy's not worthy of another second
of your love and your time
and your affection and i try
i try but it's just so much in a day he
says i spend too much time on
social media like i get that but i just
i don't have the motivation right now to
do any of anything
yeah you know have you left before
yeah i i just came back like a week ago
or
yeah about a week ago so you moved out
okay so how was that time away
it was very good um it's it's hard you
know living somewhere else
yeah why'd you come back you little
monsters
um well i just i want i missed him
and i want my kids to be around their
dad
hey i don't want my kids around a guy
like that
i don't want my kids around a guy like
that i don't want myself
i don't want my friend nikki around a
guy like that
now here's the thing he may understand
that exercise especially for folks with
postpartum
is really good for you he may understand
that scrolling social media is not good
for you
right and he's right on both of those
things
but he also needs to know that beating
up on
a struggling mom of two tiny little
babies
clear there's other things going on in
your relationship
clearly and if he is somebody who has
chosen not to commit to you
after six years and two kids together
and now he's putting ultimatums
on you because he wants his old life
back and
it's your job to get that old life back
for him
then he's not somebody that's going to
be there long term for you
okay do you hear do you hear what i'm
saying
yeah you know i'm right aren't i
you are right yeah and i know my mind is
like
you know if he's not willing to marry me
you know and not be like well maybe if
you because he says this is like
this is the job interview and if i want
the reason why
wait wait six years and two kids and
you're interviewing
yeah i know nikki
you know who wouldn't put up with that
crap jocko
and i won't either you're worth more
than that
are you struggling right now yes
is exercise always i tell them it's just
a season we're in the thick of this so
we're in the thick of this right now
and it's just it's like it's in one ear
and out the other doesn't care
just it's like the only thing he sees is
the house and the house is a little
messy we've got dishes and we've got
dirty laundry and there's toys
everywhere and that's all he sees i
swear that's all he sees
and so one of jocko's core tenants is
when you see a challenge
fix it yeah and what every husband
who's got a wife with a two-year-old and
a seven month old in the house
should do is step up and help with the
dishes
for crying out loud and the vacuuming
and the laundry
and i don't care how many jobs you're
working i don't care how busy you don't
care how tired you are
as you mentioned you're in a season when
it's winter
everybody puts on a jacket everybody
has to de-ice the driveway everybody has
to do different things in winter because
it's winter
and when you have a two-year-old and a
seven month old everything feels a
little bit heavy is that right
oh yeah okay and now listen
i will tell you in a more gentle way you
will never go wrong
putting those kids in a double stroller
and going for a long walk ever
you will never go wrong by being on your
phone less
right and you know that right oh yeah
you'll never go wrong by by um
making a list of the things that you
need to do in a day
and really leaning into them to use
jocko language to crush those things on
that list
however big or small they are and
sometimes they're a small
for a mom with a seven month old and a
two-year-old sometimes it's as small as
i'm gonna make the bed i'm gonna take a
shower
and i'm going to fill in the blanket i'm
gonna do one thing around here
right and you're going to sit down with
him y'all are going to plan that out
and i would recommend doing it to the
day but if he said the words to you this
is a job interview
i want i want you to walk out the job
interview
because you don't want to work there you
know what i mean
you don't want to work there and that is
scary and that is terrifying and that is
frustrating that guy does not deserve
you
um okay yeah
you don't deserve to be interviewing
after six years and kids i know
i i i i completely agree okay so what's
stopping you
what what's stopping you i i don't want
a broken family
it is broken
it is you running around with duct tape
doesn't make your tile floor not
cracked yeah
and what's happening is these these two
little kids are obs are
figuring out wow this is how this is how
parents act
this is how two people who play house
and love each other act
does that they treat each other yeah
yeah
you know what i mean i i get it i i get
it
this is how a grown man
treats the wife of his two little babies
you know yeah and that's that's what i'm
afraid of
don't be afraid of it because when you
say i'm afraid of it that's like saying
a bear might come
this has come it is at your door it is
in your home
okay gosh i know i know so when
when he when you were off at your dad's
house
was he calling you saying hey come home
come home i'm sorry
he well let's let's
let's make note that there was not any
i'm sorry thrown into this at all okay
um he said he wanted to
but he didn't want to seem desperate
and i'm like what we're not date like
we're not like at the beginning of our
relationship
you don't have to play it cool i i can't
date a robot anymore
i need to know like feelings i need to
hear these
these feelings i don't want to be
desperate
i know i don't want to seem desperate
and i was like what do you mean
desperate like if your
wife and your two babies leave your
house that is the definition of
desperate
and it was so funny i got it oh god it
was so funny he called me because
he was like hey the lights are out how
do you pay the electric bill
your lights got cut off no
we did i didn't pay it in time and so
he's like hey could you pay this for me
i mean using his card and stuff and he
pays for it but he didn't know how to
so like i think that's a little
desperate honey okay so here's the deal
nikki here's what i want you to do in
all seriousness and
i know that you are laughing to keep
this
overwhelming tide of grief to come over
you is that fair
yeah definitely okay so i want you
to today call
a local counselor in your area and
set up an appointment for just you okay
okay
spend whatever you got to spend for
child care call whoever you got a call
um if you got to drop them off at your
dad's house drop them off at your dad's
house
but i want you to go see somebody and i
want you to lay out
here's what's happening and if you want
to try and save this really i was gonna
say save your marriage but it's not even
one
um you have a daughter
i have two sons two sons okay so one of
your sons comes home
in 22 years 23 years 24 years
and says hey mom you know susan i've
been dating for six years
we're having a second kid and i told her
this is gonna be a great try out for her
to see if she's gonna be the one we're
sticking around
what would your response to that boy be
i'd be so
mad at him that's right
that's right
yeah yep okay and i want you to treat
yourself with that same level of care
i want you to treat those babies that
same level of care my deepest wish
is that your husband goes what am i
doing
or your boyfriend does goes what am i
doing and he snaps out of it
okay and maybe he's misreading jocko
and misreading the understanding of what
that guy talks about
but the root of what he talks about is
ownership
responsibility accomplishing a mission
right not berating a
exhausted frustrated
postpartum mother of their two babies
okay into every guy out there listening
to this
stop stop
you want your wife to get off social
media give her a place worthy of being
off social media for
you and a wife who's not so exhausted
all the time pick up the crap around the
house
sit down and have that conversation with
her and say how can i honor you today
and i know you're off making the money i
know you're off
doing your work blob feeling whatever
cool
you know you're not doing dragging
around two little kids
wife's been out of town for a few days
and i've had the kids at my house
coming into work is a blessing and a
gift in a safe safe quiet place
and it's been like three days
not day after day after day after year
after year nicki i'm so sorry this is
happening to you and i'm sorry to
tell you this but you know
i'm not telling anything new right right
yeah is your dad in your corner is your
mom in your corner
definitely okay so i want you to lean on
them but today i want you to
go make an appointment with a counselor
and start getting the help and care that
you need
and either come up with a
a if then if now if not now then
conversation with your boyfriend
a practice conversation or an exit
strategy
sooner rather than later you are not on
a job interview
you are not trying out for this guy's
love
you're better than that you got more
than that
husbands create a home for your wives so
they don't want to be on social media
they want to be with you
create an environment where they've got
space to go exercise and move their
bodies into walk
because there's not 40 other things that
you've given them to do or they feel
obligated to do in this space so they
don't even have time to take care of
themselves
create a world where your partner's got
space man
i i hate that for you nick i'm
heartbroken for you she's louise i don't
even know how to end this show man
um no you know what you're gonna end
this with strength
just like i told the caller earlier
you've got the pen now there's appeared
into that sentence when he said
i don't appear desperate cool
you are desperate you're at the end of
your rope and now you got a pen you get
to write what happens next
and i want you to write i matter my kids
matter
i'm worthy of being loved i'm worthy
being in a situation where
i'm not trying out where i am fully
known and fully loved
and i'm going to start taking the next
step to get there it's a teeny
tiny frustrating collapsing step but i'm
going to get there i'm going to take the
next one i'm going to lean on my dad i'm
leaving my mom i'll lean on my counselor
i'm going to lean on my friends in my
community
because this guy said he won't be there
not until i pass the tryout
which is i guess is six years and two
kids later
but you're gonna be a fierce bad man
pajama nicki
and we're all rooting for you let me
know how that conversation goes let me
know how connecting with that counselor
goes
gentlemen be better i'm saying this to
myself i gotta be better too but we
gotta be better
we gotta be better than that and if we
got friends in our lives that
talk that crap to their wives to their
girlfriends we gotta be willing to step
up and say no
absolutely not absolutely not it's not
funny it's not a joke it's not good bro
nope be better than that we got to hold
ourselves accountable gentlemen
starting yesterday